[Música]
então quando criança eu sempre fui muito
curioso
eu sempre fui a criança muito inquieta
estava querendo sempre conhecer as
coisas me divertir não aceitava muito os
limites os nãos que os meus pais me
passavam que escola me passava então eu
não ficava muito na linha da média das
crianças à escola né
na verdade como criança eu tive muitos
sonhos sonhei que estava na época do
star wars
eu tenho 48 anos eu cresci a minha
educação básica década de 70 década de
então peguei lá o lançamento de star
wars me encantava com aqueles filmes com
aqueles painéis cheios de controle com
aqueles efeitos especiais com aquelas
narrativas de espaço
participei de muitas atividades na
escola representando essa questão da
ficção científica dos filmes mas a
escola ela como vocês mesmos é mesmo
hoje puderam perceber a escola era um
lugar que eu não também não gostava
muito
me sentia muito entediado é a escola não
atendia a minha expectativa então sempre
buscava mecanismos caminhos para não
participar da aula para não estar
presente na aula e acabei virando um
político muito cedo fui líder estudantil
e como líder estudantil você se mobiliza
para fazer muitos projetos dentro da
escola fazer muitas atividades organizar
eventos enfim isso aí é eu nunca
imaginava que estaria realmente
preparando um pouco do meu comportamento
e das minhas competências para o
empreendedorismo e eu só me lembro de
dois professores na época da escola um
professor com dez anos
eu falei pra ele que eu tinha um sonho
muito
grandes e piloto e ele falou é mas você
nunca vai conseguir ser piloto por que
você não gosta de matemática
aquilo foi um balde de água fria muito
grande ea outra professora professora
que eu me lembro muito bem a professora
elzinha foi no ensino médio ela me
ajudou muito na parte de redação e eu
estudei em escola pública quase toda a
minha vida só dois anos eu estudei em
escola particular bom tinha uma
característica
na minha infância na minha identidade
quando criança quando adolescente
eu não queria esperar para realizar os
meus sonhos eu queria conquistar os meus
sonhos de uma maneira muito rápida não
queria esperar a faculdade e terminar os
estudos trabalhar como eu venho de uma
família muito simples meu pai professor
ea minha mãe costureira então eu tinha
que eu não ganhava brinquedos
raramente eu ganhava um brinquedo os
meus brinquedos meu ego da infância fui
ir pras restos de construção nos bairros
trazer azulejos de cimento e construir
cidades com restos de construção ea
única maneira que eu vi foi a poder
realizar os meus sonhos rápido foi
empreender então com 11 anos eu decidi
construir uma caixa de engraxate para
engraxar sapatos e pra rua realizar o
meu sonho e graças a deus a minha mãe
nunca foi aquela mãe que tem vergonha o
que proíbe você de fazer determinadas
coisas quando ela vê algo positivo no
interesse da criança na motivação e
então comecei atrás dos meus sonhos
então com 11 anos eu comecei engraxar
sapatos
depois foi fazer venda de porta em porta
de material de cama mesa e banho
depois vem de título de clube e aí com
13 anos foi convidado a entrar numa
empresa e decidiu então mudar os meus
estudos para a noite
comecei a estudar à noite e aí eu
comecei a conquistar muitas coisas que
eu queria que eu sonhava e muito rápido
na minha vida se acelerou muito porque
as
minhas conquistas também foram muito
rápidas com o meu dinheiro em 1984 eu
comprei o meu primeiro computador
comprei um teclado exibiu comecei a
aprender a programar nesse computador
cinco anos depois eu entrar numa das
empresas que desenvolvem software que
vende softwares para a área de projetos
que é uma uma grande referência no
brasil era muito jovem e comecei a atuar
nessa empresa na área de desenvolvimento
de projetos mas com foco da área
comercial e comecei a desenvolver muitas
competências dentro de um contexto de
projetos
o projeto você tem um problema para
resolver
você tem que reunir recursos para
resolver você tem que administrar tempo
tarefas orçamento pessoas e isso me
desenvolveu muito como como o jovem com
isso em 1996 eu decido fundados 1-azul
education for life que a nossa empresa
nós estamos aí com 21 anos não somos uma
estátua a gente começa com um foco de
levar para a escola aquilo que eu já
queria desde a época que eu era
estudante
eu queria uma escola diferente uma
escola que me motivasse que me
desafiasse que me dessem a oportunidade
de envolver o meu potencial e todos nós
sabemos que a escola hoje ela está muito
presa o conteúdo programático quando os
sistemas de avaliação e com isso a gente
lançou a área da robótica educacional no
brasil 1996 desenvolvemos uma placa
eletrônica usando me controlado na época
8051 desenvolvemos um software começamos
a levar isso para as escolas
nesse momento eu percebi que eu tinha em
mãos algo muito bom algo muito poderoso
para transformar a educação que a
robótica educacional
ela não se trata apenas de criar robôs
quem já participou de um torneio de
robótica sábias garotada tem até um lema
não se trata de criação de de alunos
criando um robô mas robôs construindo
pessoas porque é a oportunidade de você
criar de você trabalhar em equipe
resolver problemas superar desafios
reunir recursos para resolver
vem toda aquela questão da perseverança
do trabalho em equipe da capacidade de
resolver problemas né da visão sistêmica
de como as coisas funcionam
então isso começou a me encantar muito
eu comecei a perceber gente a gente tem
nas nossas mãos algo muito muito
poderoso
então nós começamos a levar isso pro
brasil todo não apenas em escolas
particulares mas também escolas públicas
né
tive oportunidade tive a oportunidade de
ver alunos que ficou com 8 9 e 10 anos
hoje são professores são tem mestrado 1
terminando o doutorado em neurociências
né
e vai atuar na área de educação e são os
jovens brilhantes não apenas no aspecto
das competências mas como pessoas têm
uma visão de mundo um desejo de
contribuir para construir um mundo
melhor
agora o maior desafio de gente como
empresa foi da escala habilidade me
frustrava muito ver robótica restrita a
um grupo de alunos numa aula extra
curricular com o professor mentor que
gosta de tecnologia gosta de programação
porque porque a gente já estava
percebendo que a robótica não é só para
quem quer entrar nas áreas de exatas ou
para os alunos geek os alunos
inteligência robótica pode ser para
todos que desenvolve as habilidades e as
competências e tem um ambiente ali onde
as coisas não estão prontas até alunos
em times de robótica que tem foco em
administrar o time prepara o time para a
viagem preparar os orçamentos buscar
patrocínios né então todo esse ambiente
de aprendizagem é proporcionado pela
robótica educacional
agora o desafio foi da escalabilidade
então eu tive a oportunidade de falar
uma viagem que para mim me marcou eu fui
até os estados unidos o meio e reúne com
um velhinho foi um dos fundadores do
media lab o senhor papa que já faleceu
falei papa e suas idéias do
construcionista do aprender fazendo da
robótica da programação da tartaruga que
é programada com a linguagem logo isso
15 anos atrás ou mais de 20 anos isso é
só ideias fantásticas podem revolucionar
a educação mas como da escalabilidade
para isso e aí eu mostrei uma ideia para
ele a gente criar uma atividade uma
metodologia onde qualquer professor
pudesse utilizar não apenas um professor
de robótica qualquer professor pudesse
utilizar e com isso nós conseguimos dar
a escala habilidade que o brasil tem
hoje
então nosso também iniciamos os torneios
de robótica no brasil em 1999 hoje os
torneios já estão acontecendo em todos
os estados já são várias ligas de
robótica
eu acho que hoje a robot que ela ganhou
uma velocidade é como nunca antes no
brasil
os alunos estão mentor isando outros
times
hoje a coisa cresce de maneira orgânica
ou muitos anos a sun por 19 anos agente
sustentou os torneios no brasil como
iniciativa social e eu tive a
oportunidade com a minha empresa de
também realizar os meus sonhos e desde
criança eu sempre tive um sonho de ser
piloto de avião e nove anos atrás eu
pude realizar esse sonho e hoje eu vou
já votei nesse caça com o nosso querido
astronauta marcos pontes e sou um adepto
da viação anfíbia então essa é o meu
sonho de infância que eu pude realizar
acreditando nele
acreditando nas pessoas que estão junto
comigo e acreditando nesse trabalho da
robótica e da cultura mec
muito obrigado pela oportunidade
[Aplausos]
[Música]